your joiner who was married to Richard
are you deserve a medal and would you do
well let's see I check people in I do
the banking and I'm the only one in the
family that's ever you know taking care
of the books and made sure that the
mortgage payment was paid why is it all
on your shoulders you just sound like
the only one who's actually in control
yes the only one no he's never even
looked at the checkbook
I've mostly tired I'm getting tired of
holding everything up and it's getting
old driving through here those vineyards
the mountains I mean you must be making
a fortune well you know I'm well I own
nine hundred ninety thousand on this and
we lose from five to fifteen thousand
dollars a month this is crazy
yeah but how can the business not be in
profit oh that's my guy I don't know
that I understand oh yeah that's that's
what I need you for ion ously have you
seen the lobby and my bedroom yeah I can
see why the hotel might be struggling
but surely the rest of us we're making
money with that view on the river like
that well the restaurant is run by dusty
my younger son okay and then Duke and
his wife run the music end of the bed
okay
but what percentage of the profits you
get none
bloody hell it sounds nuts I know it
sounds I just crazy Wow look at this
place
it's like a missed opportunity beyond
belief oh yeah that's what everybody
tells me every said you've got a gold
mine here and I go well so far I don't
film the gold this place is a patch of
heaven so I'm shocked to hear it's not
making money I can't wait to hear why
Joanna's sons aren't contributing to the
lodges finances I see first name is
Melissa Gordon nice to see you too well
hello how are you likewise my pleasure
good see Jim right yeah so this is set
up for the concert yeah I run the sound
okay mixing yeah yeah okay great how
much did you get in it's 15 $15 $15 yeah
so out of that $15 charge how much
here's the month none none well let's
say let's have a quick word outside the
place has got a million dollars debts
yeah I know and it's an and I've been
sitting waiting and I I can I can relate
I think I know what's going on here when
was last time had a smoke way earlier
this after 20 minutes ago no no no this
morning this morning
but relieves stress but it definitely
smells of a business that's run by
stoners oh yeah I know Duke isn't taking
any responsibility for the lodge
hopefully his brother will have a better
excuse for not sharing any profits with
his mum hello hello dusty dusty lucky
dusty by the sounds of things oh yes of
course I would say hello hi come on I
said it's dis chef right yeah okay great
I'm a very hard worker I think Gordon is
going to like me so are you making money
here yes sir how much more did you make
a month last month they made about
twelve thousand Wow so you went to 150
grand a year with everything working
right yeah how you don't pay a dollar
profit to your mother father occasion
the business is a million dollars in
debt you make a shitload of money and
your mum yes nothing I was shocked that
dusty makes that much and that bothers
me because he should help me out
financially know full well that you
stand to inherit this business the store
not a penny that goes in to reducing
debts and this is your mother
correct I've really devoted my life to
this place and to be treated like I
don't care about my family and don't
care about this business they really cut
to the core and I have no problem
telling him to get the [ __ ] out of here
I'll give you kick with the acid that's
my son I don't understand why the boys
are just ended for themselves why can't
the business work as one and everybody
pull together
well you haven't done a damn thing
around here I work hard here and I don't
see you do [ __ ] thing because you
can't take any criticism without wanting
to punch my [ __ ] lights out how do
you feel about this shut the [ __ ] up
both of him he hates me I said what
would you like me to do what I want to
see you grow up and turn into a real man
I want to see you oh like Huayra [ __ ]
right I want to have I want to see you
be able to go and I got no wonder this
place is on his knees thank you